hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't escape - this is a
new game made by script welder if you
don't know whose script welder is he's
made a number of absolutely phenomenal
indie games in this pixelated style when
the undead attacked we weren't ready
thinking back we were never fully ready
for this the whole outbreak started over
two weeks ago and it's been getting
worse ever since this time we've barely
made it we got away but bill got bitten
we both knew what that meant we decided
to stay in this abandoned building for a
while we needed rest and sleep a huge
horde of the Living Dead is coming this
way
they will reach us by sunset I have to
lock this place up before that happens
and maybe just maybe I will live to see
another day
good ok so this one is a sequel to don't
escape one with you if you haven't seen
ok door open there's there's a lot of
rules to this game and the first one
it's not like the traditional escape
games it's in that you need to make sure
you don't get out well the first one was
about that you just need to make sure
things don't get in for this one ok
there's some sand inside in there so I
can probably make some sand back there's
a lot of hidden details in this one that
I remember from the first game the pain
can't stand the pain
okay so Bill's gonna turn into a zombie
so I need to find a way to handle him in
a not so good way can't break it with
this well ordinarily I would be able to
okay so there's a lot of stuff that I
need to find and in the first game I
remember that there was like hidden
secrets that I could click that I wasn't
able to see before
okay found a key in the trash found
something else in the trash I gotta make
sure that I what should I place here I
don't know
traps defenses oh god this is gonna be
hard cuz I have no idea what its gonna
want from me okay out of fuel there a
broken gate so he's got oh my good oh
you kidding me are you kidding me oh you
must be kidding me I'm never gonna be
able to get this mi looks like
Slenderman is forest hey how's it going
statue hello baby how you doing okay
pile of bricks and axe go
that's from the first game oh man hello
I've lost my faith
looks like you've also lost your church
but why are you here you're not gonna
survive dude can you come with me
because I might need help or something
all right so is there nothing else I can
do over there okay bag of cements too
heavy I need to go find like a wheel
barrel something there's probably a very
specific order to be going about these
things
whoa no fuel fuel tanks intact so I can
probably oh no that's not a hose that's
okay whoo gun no ammo though okay so so
there's probably ammo and like the trunk
of that car something there's a lot of
body parts on the ground okay so the
thing about this game is like it's a
very slow paced game and that you're
trying to fight hello how are you doing
hi there I'm Jeremy I'm not a werewolf
at all you can trust me
sorry I can't see you clearly I've lost
my glasses so I could be a zombie there
is hop
it's okay whoever and wherever they are
they seem to be in a brick house okay
there's someone in there probably
someone in the basement there oh hi
how's it going now with my bare hands
how about with the axe no I can't have a
good swing shovel you sure you want to
use the shovel to kill the undead the
shovels handle doesn't seem sturdy in my
break no with that sort of precaution
okay so I probably need to shovel for
many many many many other things how
about a bottle of alcohol I love a gun
okay so I need to find ammo for the gun
or something I'm just wasting a whole
bunch of time I know but I got nothing
else to do so I got to find that guy's
glasses because he could help me survive
obviously okay oh no I'm at the shop I
need to go to the last unknown place gas
station cool
one 9-millimeter bullet cool okay so I
can get gas now from the canister
get back at that money for some reason
medicine painkillers I can give that to
Bill Bob Bobby Bo baton dubbing Bo
whatever his name was okay out of order
and out of gas
but what I can do is I can go back to
the shop I can kill this zombie with the
one Zombo bullet right here put that in
there put oh there we go okay now I can
shoot this guy are you sure you want to
use the gun it will consume one billet
and make he'll love it
oh yes BAM give give give give anything
else that I need
kablammo okay so that probably attracted
a lot of attention and made it but it's
not like the horde of zombies was not
coming a thank you in return I will help
you let's go lead the way thank you okay
so the chain okay so I might be able to
break the chain somehow because I might
need that damn it if I could get that
cart I would be able to get what I need
for the other thing okay gotta find a
way to get that out can I use the wire
on it maybe new dammit
okay that's not gonna work so I need to
go back to the base because now Jeremy
should be back right I guess none oh
yeah I was supposed to lead the way
ah thank you you're welcome you don't
look good at all paintings God thank you
but I'm still infected I don't know how
much longer I can hold it together well
I hate to say this but you probably
gotta get gone buddy good friend of mine
oh he's right here
Jeremy what really but he's just in my
inventory why is Jeremy in my inventory
oh that means he's with me okay alright
okay so me use the axe on this know
about the key on this there we go oh
damn it come on okay the keys probably
to the front door so if I if I lock the
front door I'll be able to do that this
is complicated there's a lot more to
this than the other game I might now be
able to get this all in one go I might
have to come back to it later damn it I
need to find like a hose or something I
know there's got to be secret new
daddies yes okay 9-millimeter bullet
hidden in the hole okay
I got another bullet cool I got cutter
okay metal cutter I can either use that
on the padlock or I can use that on the
chain for the shotgun guard shocking
cart the shopping cart to be able to go
where I need to go after that okay metal
cutter that lock there we go okay what's
in here all this looks happy and fun
good place to hide okay oh okay
so the idea is that after we set up all
the defenses up here we go down there to
hide and then hopefully lock it but I
don't know how we're gonna lock it
because I broke the lock ah that might
have been an issue okay but either way
oh oh I know what I have to do I know
what I have to do oh I know what I have
to do sorry bill so is it the time are
you sure you want to use the gun and
shoot bill it will consume one bullet
and make a hell lot of noise at least
you will put an end to his misery I
guess oh it's so sad I'm just gonna
leave it had to be done yeah I agree but
it's so sad though it's so sad and stuff
I could have I don't know maybe he could
have helped out with the defense by
being outside maybe you could have been
like a decoy zombie and been like oh no
people here or a burger okay so whatever
all right so there's got to be a way to
get other stuff I'll be right back
there's a lot of stuff happening here
and I don't want to waste your time you
wandering around so be right back okay
so I found a thing there apparently for
some reason I can go into the woods and
I can chop wood for branches and sticks
which I can probably sharpen into some
sort of a trap but now that I got Jeremy
with thee he's gonna help me so now I
have a bunch of pointy sticks great so
what about that okay okay maybe I can
use the metal cutter on this yes okay so
I got a shopping cart that means that I
can use the shopping cart on the metal
fence I can use a shopping cart on all
sorts of stuff I can use the shopping
cart to get what I need for the vvvv
cement bag and other stuff that's down
there in the church
okay so if I can do that good oh there
we go got the bricks got all of it can I
get that wood - no okay
so I think Oh open another 9-millimeter
bullet good for me just something behind
the church maybe maybe it's keys for
this nope okay maybe I can just bash
down the door with the axe there we go
okay got it
hello Oh rubber hose rubber hose all the
fish are dead rubber hose okay so that's
from the deep sleaze series I know that
I know that for a fact this is from deep
sleep okay Jamie I don't have time to
sit and rest I know everything is sad
okay so but oh I millimeter bullet okay
so I got another bullet that's good I
guess take care of everyone else it gets
bit by zombies okay so I don't think I
don't know if there's any book on here
that I need so I'm gonna go get some gas
I'm gonna turn that on for the generator
I don't know why I'd need that but I got
it okay so hose for that canister for
the hose fill with gas okay so now I can
go back and I can fill up the generator
at the base whatever hole that's gonna
do for me besides make some noise
generator are you sure you want to use
the fuel brother generator you will not
have any fuel left in the canister it
will produce electricity that might come
in handy
okay so I guess I can't use it for a
trap if I use it for this but I'll have
electricity which means that I'll be
able to do what I need okay real wire
fence okay ah [ __ ] that's a lot of time
okay but I guess I got all that I needed
to get outside I know that I missed some
stuff but I'm definitely gonna try to do
this okay so I got that the fence is
fixed so now if I go over here I can set
up these sharp sticks as a trap oh crap
that's more time than I have okay so I
close that lock it with this okay lock
the door that's good that's good
cement the door how about brick the door
can i brick the door
oh crap oh the window I forgot ah break
up the window mortar cement the window
cement the bricks no crap I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die celibate oh
oh ah there we go
semantics and water water water
need water there we go okay water mix it
with a shovel
good yes perfect take them ten minutes
it's totally fine I got that okay so now
I use the bricks on that or bricks on
the window oh [ __ ] Oh Ted's god dammit
how in the world was I supposed to have
enough time to do any of this crap oh
maybe I was supposed to find a way to
get the priest to join me so if I do
this I'm just gonna die right I'm just
gonna straight-up die and why is this
gonna take so long it's so bad I guess
oh I guess bill could have helped me on
that one Bob Billy here's my best friend
and I didn't even know his name
really oh this is so sad well what else
am I supposed to do oh maybe it's like
if probably is gonna kill me isn't it Oh
Oh No you've run out of time you were in
the middle of something when the Sun is
setting a horde of 50 that arrived
reckless shooting is cost additional 10
Living Dead to show up dammit dammit the
fence with your first line defense is
fought 15 members of the Horde for the
Lord took it down there was nothing in
their way in front yard the broken
window didn't stop any attack no no did
I close the latch on the downstairs
basement did I do that I'm such a dingus
up I didn't make it well that was stupid
that was really really dumb me okay so
what I'm gonna do now is I'm going to
quickly try this again without
looking at a walkthrough and if I can't
get it I'm gonna do it without you guys
watching but if I can't do it while you
guys are waiting for me to do it then
we're just going to do it another
episode i'ma fall walkthrough and do it
because holy God but I bet I can do this
I bet I can do this I know I can do this
I'm not gonna use a walkthrough I'm
gonna get this okay so BRB it's fun it's
really fun I know what I need to do I
know what I need to take a picture of
this oh it has no batteries okay so I
got batteries put that in there take a
picture and then show it to the priest
that'll give him hope that's another
person that can help me okay this is
good
it's good it's good it's good this is
good this is good okay BRB yes I've
completely given up on my hair I need a
haircut
really badly trihard mode gauge that
looks weird trihard mode 2.0 engaged
enough oh maybe
okay connect the wires to the fence
that means the fence is electrified
that's awesome I did that I did that
thing I did it okay
so now I've done the bricks he's drunk
but he's been bitten so I really don't
want to risk him but if I shoot him then
it's not gonna be good oh thanks okay
okay he's gone good okay great
okay cool all right cool so now the last
thing I need to do is I need to go down
here close that and then wait
cuz there's just an hour and five
minutes left I've got the bricks all
done I've got the traps for the sticks
out front I've got the fence closed off
and electrified
and I've got like three bullets and an
axe and a shovel so I can give like if I
can give the axe one of these guys no my
lucky would just kill him
okay so the hatch is closed I don't have
any way to really like
like completely closed it off okay here
we go there we go
yep I'm ready I'm ready what do we got
what do we got what do we got what do we
got what do we got fifty undead arrived
come on baby you're reckless shooting
has caused initial five I know that
okay the fence was your first line of
defense it's top 15 undead creatures
before the rest of them took it down 15
undead creatures got stuck on the trap
piercing themselves against the pointy
sticks not still a lot bringing up the
window was a good idea 10 of Dead's
corpses trying to enter through the
window but ended up head low I was sick
scratching locked door held up long
enough to make 10 meat craving freaks
lose Enders and wander off you were
hiding in the cellar hearing angry
growls above your head the hats was
squeaking under the feet of the undead
there weren't enough of them to clap hat
[Applause]
and then there was silence you Jeremy
and father Bernard have survived the
night it's time to move on and leave
this place
unlocked achievement I done good I done
real good I done so good I dozen super
good this was a great game I love this
series I love these types games it's
really innovative it's really
interesting and frankly it's fun so try
for yourself there might be some secrets
that I do not explore and other options
that I did not explore either maybe this
Luca
hedonism option where you can just get
drunk and then wait until everyone eats
your face but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the annotation for more videos ivan
check out don't escape one and the deep
sleep series in the description below or
in the annotations over there thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]